(rubbery sound)
- [Mark] Hey Amanda.
- Hi. Hey guys.
I just wanted to say,
I feel uncomfortable,
the guy videotaping me right now,
sent the same messages
through basically is me.
You know what I'm saying is making me feel
like he regrets helping me right now.
- [Mark] I don't regret helping you.
I would love to help you.
(Amanda laughing)
- [Mark] Good morning Amanda.
Hey, it's my second video today.
I just wanted to say my
thoughts are translated
in my machine.
So you should think about that.
Like somebody is thinking and typing,
so I'm not trying to make
that stuff the truth.
Like they can make me feel
like all of it's not the truth
so it's not healthy to really listen to me
because it makes people my
last video, because just
my last video, because it
makes me paranoid and nervous.
So I just really want to
sit down and I love Almighty
and I love Michael, Dub, everybody.
Aunty Lindsay, Mark, hey right here.
(Mark laughing)
- [Mark] Amanda how do,
how do you spend your day?
- I'm just, I just know
I should be murdered
because I'm just not fitting in.
I'm just too much of a
looker and a listener.
You know what I'm saying?
The world is on some,
we don't fuck with that.
So...
- [Mark] Amanda how do
you spend your days now?
- Well I spend my days talking to myself,
basically tryna-
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
- I mean, I can have friends,
but the system's just like you too-
I feel like all, everything I have to say
makes people, makes the world just too
nervous.
(engine roaring)
- [Mark] Where would you
like to be in a year?
- I find the system's scamming me,
'cause like I know I'm at a
point where, I mean, overall
the person I am, I became, I
hope, you know what I'm saying?
They continue to give people these systems
because it helped me feel.
I know the best me is too
much of a listener and looker.
So I'm just not ready for this world.
If you're a listener and a looker,
I just noticed you gotta have money.
Bang. You know what I'm saying?
Shit to sit on.
So, I mean, I'm a minority to so.
(Amanda chuckling)
I was just telling her
I mean, my mom died so,
or she didn't I don't know.
- [Mark] Your dad's very helpful.
- No, he's cool.
- [Mark] Your dads a great guy
He's cool.
He's a listener.
He can be.
- [Mark] You're lucky
to have the dad you do.
- Yeah.
- He's real soulful and American-
- [Mark] He just wants the best for you.
- He's perfect.
(Amanda laughing)
- [Mark] Well, you're a handful.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You're difficult.
It's too much.
I need to go.
- [Mark] Okay.
I need to go so you guys can chill.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] So Amanda, it
seems like the medication
that your dad and I are giving
you seems to be helping you.
- Yeah. My new name is Low,
so let's just keep it Low,
you know what I'm say-
- [Mark] You changed your name?
- keep it nice and pretty.
Yeah. I changed it to Low.
- [Mark] Okay.
So I just want to explain, like,
I didn't know.
I know things sometimes, so it's up to God
and the people that robot
me to remind me of things.
So I'm so sorry
for any pain that I caused
anybody or anything.
How you guys doin?
I just want to make another video
at Mark's office because I wanted to talk
about the feeling that
I get when I get high
and you guys get horny.
This is not good.
You know what I'm saying?
And how I'd act if you guys
didn't fix me up America.
And I think that I've been,
I've been acting like that so long,
it's just like, it's natural.
You know what I'm saying?
Maybe they should stop
roboting me so I can see.
But it's just like, I just don't like
we all gotta check out that feeling I get
when I get high.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not just about Michael
seeing me that I'm sloppy.
I mean, it is, but it's just like
I just don't like that feeling.
So you guys gotta check it out
and (inaudible) that's it.
- [Mark] All right.
- [Mark] All right
Amanda, what's going on?
- I was just going to say like
I'm sorry for the pain that
everybody's been through.
If you look at my storyline
I take pain very, very seriously.
When it comes to the media
and me not being in the media,
I don't care what's going on anymore.
If I hear music or something I'm just like
turn that radio off I
don't wanna hear that shit.
And I don't give a fuck what's going on.
As long as people not in rooms
in pain or people not in pain,
I've realized now I'm like
answering it directly.
So it's like, maybe I did it.
But it's like, now that I see these
like scams and how people were in a scam.
Cause I feel like I was
scammed my storyline.
You don't know what people done.
You don't know nothing
unless it's a video of them doing it.
Or even now that's manipulated.
You know what I'm saying?
People know who I am with no life.
It made me see things that
other people don't see.
And I feel like people seeing me low,
they got used to it.
So they probably reorthodoxed theyselves.
You know what I'm saying?
With certain things because
they can't sleep with it.
But that's not me getting
on them right now.
You know what I'm saying?
Just overall I don't give a
fuck what's goin' on in media.
I can't even watch TV.
That hurts me.
Like turn that off.
They just sent a feeling.
I don't know what that means.
All I know is a storyline in my head.
They like making me look stupid
and they don't want to
see me in a certain way.
And there are certain times
where they're like do this now
or this will happen.
Do this now or this is will happened.
So I don't be doing those things.
I'm like fuck it.
I wanna to get some crack.
Like I be lazy.
You get me?
Like, do this now your
whole world would change.
Do this now or somebody's going to die.
Do this now and you'll be up $2 million.
I don't be doing that
stuff in my storyline.
Like, I'm just like,
it's always a situation.
And then they had to get me
in my head right now saying
I don't know what y'all what's going on,
what y'all think, I don't
know who scammed me.
It's probably a celebrity
that thinks I'm going to
see something in the media and get mad.
I don't give a fuck,
as long as people not in pain
I don't give a fuck.
Kim K you wanna to put me in pain?
Take me out of pain right now?
We'll talk,
we'll talk business about money, money.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm sure you wouldn't mind giving me money
if you did that to me
and you're over the whole situation.
So that's just it,
it's not her it might be somebody else.
I don't know.
I'm just talking about my storyline.
- [Mark] Amanda what pain are you in?
I'm in mental pain
because I get here to cry
because then I hit it and
was like, it's not enough.
And it's like, I realized
I try to treat crack
like it's crystal or a
weed and that's a mistake.
So I might get on crystal
or weed all know is I'm always
on my way to my last hit.
And then I'm supposed to be
electrocuted or whatever.
If I'm dying and they cloning me
then I got a problem with that.
I don't want to be clone.
And I seriously don't wanna be cloned
all alone in bedrooms
where people having sex.
I seen some white girl yesterday,
they says the same things happened to her.
She was being compared to
another girl on some sexual.
And they're saying, I think
I'm cool 'cause I said that.
That's what I'm saying
somebody is scared of me
being cool and I get that,
whoever you are, I get that.
You know what I'm saying?
That's it.
- [Mark] What do you see for your future?
For my future, I see myself
getting electrocuted to death
so that all this pain will stop.
They say that switching worlds
and all that is 'til I'm dead,
I know I died before.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know if I'm on,
I'm not being seen on the low key so
this boy because he's
putting me in forever pain.
That's what I'm saying.
I just noticed right now,
nah I gotta problem with the girl.
I just thought right now.
- [Mark] Amanda.
Just know, I don't know what's going on.
So the way people are scammed,
it's like, I don't even talk.
Like nothing's going to add up to
the feeling and I have no life.
That's why I see things people don't see.
And that's why I be orthodoxing new stuff.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like, oh, we need a word to this.
We need a feelings to this.
So I don't know what I'm saying.
Ultimately overall with all this stuff.
I just know (inaudible)
I know (mumbling)
I know I think I was given a machine
with a storyline because
I don't have no friends.
I definitely can make friends.
That's what I'm saying
I know I can make friends.
So who put this?
But it's also helping me.
You know what I'm saying?
And they gave me a waist surgery
and all the stuff they're
saying in the surgery
they put something around my heart
so that when I'm electrocuted,
I'm not gon' die.
So Imma just be in forever
pain, just sitting there.
So I don't know if that's gon' happen.
(Amanda coughing)
Overall some shit right,
I got over a nervous condition,
so I don't wanna die.
But I see what y'all be on,
your faces, what be going on?
So I'm like I,
I can't be here.
And I don't like being uncomfortable.
So I'm on my way
to my last hit
gives me like a big ass speeds.
And I sit there and I do run away.
But then sometimes I
get into conversation.
I don't-
Exactly!
(Amanda exclaiming)
I don't know why every time
I get high it's in your head!
That's the machine!
I try to tell the machine,
the machine be on some
I'm just about some crack.
I'm like no,
how you give me crack it's like,
I need it for water or food.
You know what I'm saying?
So the next time I take my last hit
I'm going to get on some turnt shit
on the machine and
hopefully it'll kill me.
They sayin' in my waist surgery
that they put something around my heart.
So,
yeah.
Be on the lookout for ambulance
or somebody with a gun
or something to come shoot me
to get me out of pain.
I definitely didn't put nobody in pain.
If you see my storyline,
like nah this girl is not
gon' put nobody in pain.
That's why I can't commit suicide,
because of the seriousness
of the pain thing.
Oh, I know people with money.
They go through different situations where
it's okay to kill, it's okay to molest,
it's okay to steal and all that stuff.
And then they reorthodox
theyselves to forget.
And I'm still here.
I don't know if my storyline
became real to the world
but somebody just said, nah.
So I don't know if you're asking
like me and you don't want me to see
that you're asking like me, I don't care.
Like, but if it's going to give me gas
cause you're like a celebrity,
then let me get that gas.
You, like if you know my life,
I need love,
I need some confidence.
But overall I'm always
on my way to my last hit,
on my storyline.
If I don't get killed,
I'm thinking right now
to my last hit right now
and I turn up and you
know what I'm saying?
Then I go to the police
and I go to the mental home
I'm gonna to hit this last hit,
turn up if it doesn't kill me,
then I'm gonna go to the
police or the mental home
or go to sleep on the street
and sell my jackets off for another hit.
But I definitely gon' be
in the mental home today.
(Amanda laughing)
- [Mark] Amanda, your, your family and I
and a few other people that
have known you in the past
are trying to help you.
- No, they're not.
- [Mark] Yes we are.
- Oh okay.
(Mark laughing)
- [Mark] Yes we are.
You're the one who's being resistant.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And do you see that maybe
you're getting in your own way
in terms of maybe getting
your life together?
- If you think I'm a different person
than who I looked to you,
somebody else's orthodoxing that.
And they telling me to
show me that I'm nothing,
and that, to teach me
a, to show me what I am
to the world versus what
the storyline is telling me.
But I don't have no life
and we don't have no life.
You see things exactly the way they are.
It's telling me that certain things
that is boosting my confidence
but y'all gotta see that that
fuel is going somewhere else.
Other than me thinking I'm all that.
And it's telling me
that in a textbook science project,
mathematics way that
that's what's going on.
There's different me's
running around here electronic
around the city and stuff like that.
And I want to know who is doing that.
You need to stop,
because where I am I'm
not gonna annoy nobody,
I'm not gonna do nothing
Exactly!
Today I said, when I was smoking,
I'm like in the cut and
then I'm gonna get murdered.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
I'm behind the scenes.
I'm annoying everybody.
And then I get murdered.
I definitely know I'm not
supposed to be here anymore.
I look very young.
Somebody take my growth spurt,
whatever out of my body.
That's what I'm saying,
whoever this is, you.
That's what I'm saying for future,
for future reference if
somebody is scamming you
don't get on them on some,
you know what I'm saying?
Get on the problem.
You know what I'm saying?
Thinking you're all that.
So what was I saying just now?
I forgot.
But I know the main thing is
that's what's goin' on.
So,
I'm not out here tryna be nobody else.
The storyline is trying
to show me something,
but that I fuel for the confidence thing
is going somewhere else
and I can feel it all day.
And if you see me out here,
the Amanda with skin,
I'm real humble.
So just know that-
- [Mark] Amanda, you-
- I like how that (inaudible)
- [Mark] Amanda you spend your entire,
you spend your day just
basically looking for fre-
- They tryna scam me off some
me on the computer at home.
I just be on YouTube all day
- [Mark] Amanda.
listening to music and Tumblr that's it.
Amanda.
- So whoever trying to
scam me, they need to stop.
- [Mark] Amanda, you basically
spend your day hunting
looking for crack, right?
- Yeah. I'm on my last hit.
I have a storyline in my head.
I'm on my last hit.
I'm thinking my voice is
being done by somebody else
who's sitting at home with their homies.
And they're doing this because
of something that happened
with my ex boyfriend.
Where he was cheating on me,
cheating on me at his job.
I'm at home, calling him all day.
The women are going to his job to cheat.
And they're saying this
shit hits basically
this hot hits because basically
I don't wanna keep bringing up this stuff
because I know people with money,
boss niggas or (inaudible)
they like to go,
they don't like to remember the same stuff
their whole life.
So I feel like I'm being a burden.
You know what I'm saying?
To these people and I don't
even hang out with 'em.
So they're saying something about some
they don't want me to be the face of it.
Every time they bring it up,
they don't wanna know.
She put me on to that.
So I'm trying to tell them first one,
I ain't finna be running around here,
telling everybody about it.
If I become close to
somebody, I'll tell them
but I don't want no
lawyers heat or nobody.
So that's it.
That's it.
Bye.
- [Mark] Bye Amanda.
- But yeah, overall (censored)
cheated on me and (censored)
and I'm calling him all day
and it makes the sex better.
You know what I'm say?
That makes the sex hit.
So they said that they
gave me the storyline
that down here and the surgery,
because that happened and I
keep escaping or whatever.
And sometimes I get caught
up in my conversation.
Just regular.
Exactly. I'm always in
regular conversation
with myself all the time.
So you think I'm getting high,
thinking I'm a speaker
or something when that's what
I'm doing all day anyway.
So that's it.
Hopefully I get a forty (inaudible).
- [Mark] You do miracles,
that's what I see.
- [Amanda] Thank you.
- [Mark] All right darlin'
- [Amanda] If you're tryna come down here
and help somebody, your
family, I don't try to
be a person ain't nobody or
tryna seem like somebody else.
Like I said the storyline is telling me
it's trying to show me that I'm not
important or that.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- [Mark] I get what you're saying.
- [Amanda] But I think overall
if celebrities are getting
cloned by my machine
my machine just told me today my machine
somewhere where nobody
can find it because my-
(sound fading out)